how skewed on me know how skip off we go
how you go yeah it's nice another Weaver
we don't have girlfriends oh my god look
around you little we full hour we can
have for why those instruments love to
dream up Love Me Tender love me please
notice what these two have in common
what impressive people from Uzbekistan
over here my shoulders all the way to
Key West
Oh amazing I never considered that a
Masjid in Key West only fire only 501
hamdulillah isabella near Hawley police
animal body al hamdu Tom alhamdulillah
Camden Kadir on tiny bunny or Bullock
titan a high rank a deer on Bob an
adulterer ankle in Woburn we open a
messiah to burden what a slim
Ellen Nabeel most powerful Kareem
on a nice little road trip cut it to Key
West and we got a nice mustard out there
we're visiting right yeah what's the
name of it Malik Malik must sit in Key
West I bet you guys didn't know about
that well we're gonna go ahead and bring
that to you soon
we're almost there you try to try to
stay what kind of food you like that you
started you stay away from fake food
yeah of course again we do our best to
eat organic very important how important
is it I mean to eat good food it's a key
to health right if you don't need
healthy food you can see the people how
they got fed with this junk food yeah
it's poison
of course you have to be healthy take
care of yourself cuz Allah let you use
this body have take care of this this is
a gift that's right this is the vehicle
that gets us to life
we got honor cherish it develop
nutritional integrity so we're gonna get
some real food over here almonds cashew
look at the beautiful
what a lost month Allah talks about the
Taibbi right it's a good look now we're
at the first grade level we're not
talking about the spray the GMOs but we
just turn them on nowadays because when
you go into the center aisles it's all
fake food you got over a half a million
you know that there's over a half a
million fake food items so we're at the
end of the aisle and we're the best the
fruits and vegetables are look at that
this is what the craters blessed us with
look at all this real food now so we're
looking for some some real food there's
still date how's that let's do that you
see the thing here is you know many
people talk about the sugar the sugars
and you look you have natural sugars
with the fiber and all the components
because Allah created heavens on earth
put everything in a in a perfect balance
right but you want to stay away from the
processed refined sugars right anything
made in the lab made in a plant no but
if it comes from a plant from the earth
eat it let's do this what do you think
about dates you like dates
huh beautiful that's right
you know what's interesting is I saw
this this magazine and you reminded me
of the life that many of our youth and
even adults get drawn into inside the
brutal world of the Mafia but notice
what these two have in common they lived
that life they had all the power money
fame women all the things you can eyes
but they're all gone they left this
world so anybody chasing this type of
life this fake life and wasting their
time their efforts the beautiful gift of
the God Almighty Allah has given us it's
your chance to turn away end up at the
end wasting a beautiful life with a gift
of life and you end up either in prison
like both of them down they ended up in
prison right and they just destroyed
that chance that they had so don't don't
end up like that all right
gangster life as Muslims when I
gangsters when I try to be gangsters you
know we are we are warriors in the path
of the Deen striving and struggling to
submit daily to be righteous to be
upright human beings all right guys we
made it to Key West
Key West Florida and we're looking for
the Masjid probably made a really good
point someone said that you said you've
traveled all over the world and if
someone tells you there's not a Muslim
there that there or mustard they're
lying huh all over the world everywhere
about to prove it
they say one in four people that's why
it's very important in the growing
Islamophobia that you get to know a
Muslim you connect with Melissa's one in
four human beings
the world are Muslim remember a Muslim
is simply one before has chosen to take
that free will that God Almighty has
given us and not to submit to a human
being to money to fame to power to
anything in creation and to take that to
submit to the crater that happens in
earth and our brother Ali was mentioning
it's the first commandment the first
commandment that God Almighty is only
one that's what a Muslim is one who has
submitted to the creator of the universe
God Almighty in Arabic Allah so we're in
to us I think we found our Mustang
went upstairs
amazing I never considered that a
mustard in Key West Florida
Ali was right we found it mustard or
Melek in Key West Florida fortunately
it's closed
oh it's open and for our brothers and
sisters humanity a mustard it's simply a
house of worship a house of prayer where
you go to congregate to come together to
worship together to the creator of the
heavens in earth and we found the
mustard here in Key West and 99 names of
Allah source of peace holy the merciful
the beneficent the forgiver the all
loving the Almighty the brothers here
are praying at a hymn to the Masjid when
you come into a Mustin you pray two
units of prayer and put the highest part
of man to the lowest part of the ground
and you say some Hannah don't be an
addict glory be to my Lord the Most High
give thanks and praise to the creator of
the heavens and earth so I'll check back
in with you they pray I'm gonna go ahead
and pray it's pretty cool we found some
some chickens over here in Key West
[Music]
so we walk from the one end all the way
to the other end water and now just a
little further more and we hit the edge
of Key West falling right back into the
water
have a look here we made it to the end
of Key West
few more steps and we take the plunge
yeah well kuba me [ __ ] you oh yeah we're
looking for the how many miles from here
to Cuba
nary 90 miles from Matty - Matty my
phone - ah he was we think he to go to
Cuba there yeah house Cuba me know how
Scoob off we go how you go
yeah it's nice that we were a little
friends
we don't have girlfriends oh my god look
around you
yellow we for lower we can have four
wives but no girlfriends all right oh
yeah the guy's crazy
all right guys we got to make sure we
don't we take care of them see that's
the thing
all right we don't use them and abuse
them I let them go all right work with
my country q1 is very nice how long it
take up if you fly there how long is on
the Panda 35 30 well that's it
except did you ever meet any Muslim in
your life and your life Muslim you ever
meet any Muslim in your life oh yeah
yeah yeah you have yeah now you've met
three three we're tourists not
terrorists all right guys only five door
only five in the Key West we just came
car this beautiful beautiful tree never
seen anything like this take a look
you see and then my father asked our
friend here what's your name sir mark
mark my father asked mark he said who
made the tree and Mark said the Lord the
Creator that heavens in the earth the
one guy that's right who created who
created a tree see those are the kind of
things we got to get people to reflect
who created a tree who created this Sun
who created the moon that's the whole
idea of this Deen is to direct people to
the worship of the one who created all
these things for us but not to worship
the creation my father asked down the
wheelchair I see that beautiful tree he
said who created that the guy stopped
his dog he said God
so then when he left he asked his friend
the same thing he said he has the you
turn off this video and forget
everything else don't forget that
worship the Creator not the creation
we've gotta breathe good-for-nothin yeah
that's the key thing remember that man
always no matter what you're doing look
the brothers
reminding us it's time to make Sal I
cannot go on we've got your day and be
heedless of that you got to know that
anywhere you're at when it's time to mix
a lot it's time to pray you got to stop
everything go you got that window of
opportunity now lost mantle has made it
easy look if you're traveling you get to
combine the salon don't lose it don't
lose your head don't lose your hereafter
over the dunya it's crazy because Allah
make it easy for us the religion the
only trouble we can combine the prayer
is you know I don't understand you have
to be grateful for everything I like you
look at this beauty all who create is
Allah and you don't want to prostrate
and say thank to yoga it just doesn't
make sense to me make it make sense man
let's go pray come on guys hear that
what time it is it's time to make salon
it's a lot of time man we're here in Key
West how you doing
have you heard about the Deen show no
it's right there next to you look at
that amazing let's look at the chord is
right next to now how did that happen
Bastion yes where you how you doing good
we're nice to meet you amazing so I'm
gonna leave it I'll leave you curious
you get a chance since it's already
there usually put you know check it out
how did it end up there I don't know
looked at my card is right there there
last night I don't know but it's here
now it's yours it's yours now what are
you doing I I do a talk show so I called
the Dean show so now don't let it get
lost it's yours
nice to meet you brother all weekend
put the seat in the people's heart
analyzed the waffle wanna grow the city
this whole idea to tell him about the
Dina Jill evolved a la explain him tell
people and he accepted you know he
believed that God is one and he's do
awful create us and we have to be
grateful the purpose of his life is
serve for your gun
Sophie Oh God so you can have eternal
life up to one God worship Him alone be
grateful be thankful and be a good human
being
how's that sound let's keep going here
the Key West the creator's make the
whole earth with such to a place of such
that where you can go ahead and make the
prostration to take the time out but
we're back at again mustard and Melek
[Music]
a young
[Music]
Oh
Oh No Aloha
along
[Music]
so many people when they see some of
this calligraphy they can appreciate it
because they don't know what it means
but imagine on the wall if it was
translated into English and it said I
bear witness that there's nothing worthy
of worship except the creator of the
heavens on earth God Almighty along
witness that for instance if you're
living there in time of Jesus it would
say that Jesus is the Messenger of God
today living there in this time you
would end it with and Muhammad is the
messenger so there's nothing worthy of
worship versus a negation that you're
negating that there is no deity in
creation a man is not God
a Saint messenger the Sun the moon
anything that you can envision imagine
that you could touch feel that's not God
so its first a negation and then an
affirmation affirmation is affirming
what's in your very nature that there's
only one God there's no deity worthy of
worship except the one God the Creator
that Jesus worshiped at Abraham that
Moses that the last and final message
and the tender
okay Mohamed abortion that's that
testimony here
need to see it in that in the
calligraphy it appreciate it now right
maybe you won't even recite it and say
it huh
think about that one repeat after me ash
hadu an la illaha illallah WA ash hadu
ana muhammadan abduhu wa soon
go ahead simple it's easy but it's
life-changing it brings peace and
contentment at heart when you start to
implement it and you live it also the
majority are from Uzbekistan
so you get a congregation of over 30
that come to the Friday Juma here in Key
West Florida and the majority said
they're from from his Bukka Stan yeah
majority tell us something about is
Becca Stan where's that Rebecca stan is
a hero aysia
it's like countries they were back in
the days with in Soviet Union this is
the G key Stan was biggest and
Kyrgyzstan Afghanistan they're all
together in this area there was video
now they break up and they all your
country's very impressive people from
Uzbekistan over here Michelle all the
way to Key West all the way in Kia who
you ask my brothers I'll see you guys
soon we see our brothers over there from
Uzbekistan
I get all that confused now packaged
it's Pekka now text and it's me who's
Becca Stan Checketts tan
Tajikistan you know who you are my
brothers I'll see you soon inshallah I
still sing not professionally I still
sing but without music because I find I
can say I kinda I'm an born but new
Muslim I'm a new Muslim now when I hear
that music instruments is Shaytan
and I really I was investigating and I
find the truth that the instruments
music today is is exam like you call us
for to play those instruments love to
dream up
Love Me Tender love me please never let
me
from Islam from Islam now that's why I
give up detail are you so see miss be a
professional like good bucks
Keywest you see a lot of chickens
randomly just pop up out of nowhere
roosters chickens pretty cool footage
what if order soup yeah but hook up with
the brothers from from Kyrgyzstan
kurkistan this time I see so I'm gonna
forget this name and this is where I
believe 90 miles to robot Cuba the Cuba
kuva there's a nice mustard out there in
the community so inshallah maybe they
can be on cue but what do you guys think
- Deshawn Cuba health care what do you
think Trinidad brother I think it's a
beautiful place and all the mothers over
there so we need to visit a shower yeah
what do you guys think how about the
Dean show and Trinidad let us know what
you think you know what I usually think
brother when I see the beautiful
creation the Christian of the Creator
Allah you see it you observe it you know
the beautiful trees the ocean and
everything but can you imagine some
people you know they just look for this
but and they end up listening to these
rap videos and seeing the celebrities
and they want to acquire that and they
fight and kill just to get you know that
big mansion the money and the you know
the parties and the fame and then it's
gone you lose it but the believer you
know obviously he's working hard to to
enjoy the Halal things in this lake but
man when you imagine if Allah created
the beautiful things here what will he
have for us and Genma what do you think
about that I don't think we can't even
imagine this
you know because like I'm a magical book
we have a lot of Hadees describe what
we're gonna have in Paradise can you
imagine I read this somewhere that says
they're gonna bring your fruit when you
taste this fruit they're gonna bring you
the same food but this one's gonna have
a million sand know a different taste
there's gonna be unlimitedly different
tastes on the one foot so there's like
what amazed me the people believe that
iPhone or the cars have a creator right
somebody create but they look around and
they think there's no creator - Oh
everything else doesn't make any sense
share some some insight here and
hopefully can be of some great benefit
what do you think brother beautiful